[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we knew him when he used to be just a
newspaper writer now
he's a tv guy espn packers reporter rob
great to have you back
um are you ready for a little drama over
the next couple of weeks months
dan if it takes a sticky quarterback
situation for you and i to get back
together then
so be it bring it on if i said on the
drama meter
give me a number between one and ten
where are we right now
in green bay uh it's
eight or nine man it's uh it's right up
there
um this is um been building for a while
the thing that surprised me dan was that
rogers
and his people allowed it to become
public because we knew this was
festering
for a while but rogers as you know is a
very smart
calculated guy never does anything
without thinking it through
and his history suggested that
he would keep this and make passive
aggressive type of
gestures but never really come out
and go all out with what he was thinking
and in this case
he did do we know that his camp was the
source of this leak on draft day to
shefty
well put it this way dan why would the
team
want this out there right i mean first
of all they don't want anyone knowing
their quarterbacks unhappy because they
have no intention
of trading it now if they wanted to
trade him sure they would put it out
there but
there is no way that they don't want to
go forward with aaron rodgers
in 2021 the issue is do they want to go
forward with them
beyond so like that said right there
that eliminates that side of the
equation in terms of who put this out
there and look
for aaron to say at the kentucky derby
i'm disappointed
that this news came out who was he
fooling
well i just wonder were they trying to
embarrass him to let everybody know that
how petty he is how petty he's being
that
you know i i i as soon as i heard it i
go okay
who leaked it and and why and
you know it's just like when uh diana
roussini this morning said
shailene woodley is in the meetings with
the packers front office at aaron's home
okay who would leak that rob right yeah
that
that is curious um it's a good question
but everything from what i can gather
and tell that this
initially did not come from the team
side okay
where do we go from here yeah well right
now
i think it's a stalemate for a couple of
reasons one
um june 1st nothing if they're going to
trade them it's not going to happen
until june 2nd
i told greeny this morning on get up
just book me for june 2nd
at 7.05 uh because that's when we can
have something again concrete now i'm
sure we'll talk again
but like from a salary cap standpoint
just if they didn't trade them before
the first round of the draft where they
were going to get immediate capital it
would be salary cap suicide
to do it before june 1. so at this point
we've got
you know what a few weeks of posturing
back and forth
but i think the packers still truly want
to
uh to try to make this work um it's
interesting dan i i asked a highly
placed
team source yesterday if there's any
update
and the answer was uh not unless you can
tell me our quarterback is coming back
does everything go away
if the packers do fire their gm as it's
been reported that aaron wants him out
i don't think they're gonna do it dan
that's just not the way they've they've
done business forever um you know right
or wrong
they have never really put the
quarterback above everybody else do you
believe that story though rob
that rogers dislikes
brian gooda koons not much i don't know
whether he wants him
fire dan but i know that is for sure the
source of his
of his uh problems and it's not just the
jordan love picks
um you know there's been all kinds of
things he didn't want jordy nelson let
go
when jordy nelson still had you know
good football left in him
i remember in training camp was it last
year or the year before
where he listed it was last year he
listed off i feel feel really good about
my top
four receivers marquez valdez gantling
alan lazard
uh davonte adams of course and jake
kumaro the next day they cut jake coomer
you know like i mean he wouldn't have
gone out on a limb and put jake kumaro
in that
if he thought they were going to cut him
and that i think he felt like that
undermined him so
he has forged a really good relationship
with matt leflore
and in fact better than i thought he
would knowing how difficult
that he can be to work with and how it
ended with mccarthy credit to him
for buying into the floor there's not an
issue there except maybe they should
have kicked the
they should not have kicked the field
goal on fourth and eighth nfc
championship you were there when rogers
was drafted
do you remember what farbs react because
it's a first round draft pick they
didn't trade up
rogers fell into their lap and rod and
farv wasn't playing that well back then
so right that's different rogers right
but remember this
dan remember when brett favre famously
said it doesn't say in my contract
and i have to help aaron rodgers get
ready and that first year
man it was frosty it really was it was
bad he did
everything he could to freeze him out
now it did improve like you go back and
look at
oh six when mccarthy got in and 07 when
they went to the nfc championship game
i mean there's plenty of plays where you
see barb come running off the field
after throwing a touchdown and rogers is
right there ready to give him
the hug so it definitely changed but man
at the beginning
it was it was just it was frosty to
rogers credit
he didn't freeze out love he said he's
like look
i'm not thrilled with the pick but it's
not jordan love's fault
well you start to look at this and you
go okay
so rogers the offense is good enough for
him to win the mvp
the skill position players are good
enough so the front office
did a pretty good job i i think we could
all be in agreement right
yeah i mean there's the narrative that
they haven't done enough but they have
the number one scoring offense they
resigned
uh the best left tackle in the league
and david bactiary they resigned the
best
you know maybe the best running back in
terms of touchdown production and aaron
jones
so you say well they didn't do a lot in
free agency well those were their free
agents right so i would agree with that
premise
but also if i said if i go back five
weeks
five weeks ago and i say to john lynch
and kyle shanahan with the niners
don't make that trade with miami yeah
get all those draft picks
and you're probably gonna have to throw
in a defensive starter
and you could get aaron rodgers
yeah well i think that with the night
trying to get aaron rodgers on thursday
i know but they didn't have any draft
picks like they had the third pick
overall
yeah but if i said to sam do you think
san francisco
if they had a chance to get rogers
would they would they have done that
five weeks ago
yeah you're probably right they probably
wouldn't have in terms of making the
trade they made to get to three
but here's the thing dan like the
packers have sold everybody all along
we're not trading it now when does that
change you know how hard of a stance is
roger's going to take i mean what
do we is it is it june is it when
training camp starts
july 28th or whatever it is when the
season opens september
7th now when is it that's like i mean
you how many times did we talk
during the summer of five i mean it was
like you know the thing
went on like the packers mo has been
don't do anything until you absolutely
have to um
i.e ignore it and hope it goes away
which they found out then
stuff doesn't go away how's rogers
viewed
locally yeah you know what people love
him because he wins
um i'm not so sure he's beloved
because of who he is like brett favre
was no it's a different time right dan i
mean like
brett favre was downtown on washington
street you know doing shots
on the bar and you know pouring drinks
in everybody it's just
it can't happen now right i mean it's
just the the social media the
the camera phones it just he'd be
destroyed
uh far couldn't exist but barb was the
every man right like he
um you lived through everything with him
you grieved with him when his dad died
he
he cried when he talked about his pain
killing addiction
uh you know he was out front when his
wife had breast cancer roger's much more
private
um you know much quieter he now he has
opened up in recent years um has become
a little bit more
uh letting the public in but it's just
not the same
in terms of the belovedness not of the
player
dan but of the person what role does
shailene woodley play in this
i'm not touching that one brother
remember olivia munn came after me i'm
not touching that one yeah
why did she come after you oh she
thought that i wrote that he was not
playing well because
of his relationship which is not at all
what i wrote and she
took a shot at me on twitter and it all
went crazy from there so
i i have learned i'm not touching that
did she call you did rogers like
what is your relationship like with you
yeah so rogers when that happened with
olivia rogers called me over in the
locker room the next day and say hey
look i understand what you wrote
i don't think it's a big deal but she's
she's
upset about it so next time you know
just keep her out of this and he
slapped me on the shoulder walked away
and i thought it was over
and then two days later she went after
me on twitter
so and then it just went you know then
it was i blamed her
which was not you know what i did but uh
no i i mean my relationship with aaron i
would categorize as good um he and i
have
done two um he's done two one-on-one
interviews with me in the last
four or five months for both for stories
um
that were pretty you know interesting
one was about his incredibly low
interception number
when he reached 400 touchdowns and it
was on new year's eve actually
and we talked for probably a half hour
while he was driving home and
in fact he stopped to get a bottle of
dom perignon which i didn't even know
you could buy in green bay
but he stopped to get a bottle of dom uh
on his way home and had to interrupt the
call and then we talked um right before
the jeopardy stuff
aired and i would say um you know both
times
uh they were good our relationship isn't
a good place he likes to call me bob
which i he knows i hate i'm rob
not bob um so i think there's a good
relationship there now
am i gonna call him up and he's gonna
tell me everything no
that's not where our relationship's at
who's the quarterback for the packers
week one rob
bob um
i don't know who it is but i don't think
it's aaron rodgers
i think there's a less than five percent
chance that it's aaron rodgers
i'd say it's 50 50 that it's jordan love
and i say that because dan
this was never the plan to get him ready
for 2021 it was
2022. he was the third stringer last
year like
he wasn't even active on game day so
this wasn't a plan
i think they almost have to go out and
get um and i'm not saying it's this guy
because he's under contract with another
team but an
andy dalton type of player a joe flacco
type of player someone that a veteran
that can come in learn the system
quickly uh and help and then bridge the
gap
between rogers and love oh i'm envious
of you you got
you got drama over the next couple of
months you thought you were going to
have an easy summer didn't you ron
you know i had played uh more golf last
summer i think that i had
in the previous few years i there's no
way i had 65 rounds last year i'll be
lucky to get
half that many i do remember you calling
me and doing your show once
during the fire saga from a driving
range i was hitting balls just about to
go play with
somebody's bro so i'm fully ready for
that
oh we're fritzy's gonna reach out to you
that's for sure
it's uh it's great to reconnect with you
rob uh happy for your success thanks for
joining us
you guys are the best i love you that's
uh rob demofsky espn packers reporter